so we finally have the scoring from the
Congressional Budget Office for this new
Trump Republican tax plan and it's
basically exactly as I told you which is
that it is going to add an insane amount
to the debt over the next ten years we
did sort of like a full analysis of the
Donald Trump Republican tax proposal we
looked at tax brackets which are a big
part of it we looked at how deductions
would change we looked at the personal
exemptions which is another part of it
we talked about the repeal of the estate
tax how pass-through income would be
differently taxed we looked at all of
that stuff and as I kind of told you
last time
if everybody gets a tax cut or if most
people get a tax cut especially the rich
people and you don't create new revenue
and you don't drastically cut spending
you're going to add to the deficit and
the CBO the Congressional Budget Office
which is nonpartisan usually for Trump
if it's a if it's Obama who has
something scored by the CBO the CBO is
in the tank for Obama you can't trust
the CBO if Trump is president and the
CBO says something good about a Trump
proposal then all of a sudden the CBO is
very trustworthy again but of course as
soon as a Trump proposal or a Republican
proposal that trumps Trump likes is
scored not favorably by the CBO as
happened with Trump care 1.0 2.0 and 3.0
then the CBO is bad again but in any
case the CBO is a nonpartisan entity
that scores proposals they have scored
this and they have indicated that the
latest version of the Trump Republican
tax cut plan tax reform plan will add a
staggering one point seven not million
obviously not billion but trillion
dollars to the debt over 10 years if it
passes and that's how these bills are
measured over the the impact on the
deficit over 10 years the math of it is
pretty simple right which is revenues
would be cut by 1.4 trillion as a result
of the tax bill and then the cost of
servicing debt would up the total
deficit increase of the bill by 1.7
trillion dollars I read a separate
analysis which pointed out that of the
1.7 trillion
10% of that alone would be because of
the estate tax change which means that
10% of this deficit addition is for not
the 1% but the top 0.2% I told you when
we did our analysis of the tax plan that
because there's already a five and a
half million dollar per person exemption
in the estate tax or an 11 million
dollar per couple exemption what we are
talking about is the richest 0.2 percent
of Americans that would benefit from the
change to the estate tax that's proposed
and that alone represents 10 percent of
the deficit increase from this bill so
where is the deluge of fiscal
conservatives and small government
whatever's coming out of the woodwork
furious that this is going to explode
the deficit you can take a position if
you want that the debt doesn't matter
but if that's your position you have to
take it no matter who's president and no
matter whether the debt or deficit are
increasing as a result of tax cuts for
the rich or social welfare programs you
can't only be against increases to the
deficit when it's Obama proposing
something that would increase the
deficit by the way he reduced the
deficit but okay with the deficit
increases if the proposal is from a
Republican or for Donald Trump
so you have to prepare yourself for the
spin from the right all this they'll say
hold on a second liberals you never
cared about the debt before so why do
you all of a sudden care about the debt
and deficit now that's a red herring
it's not that the left is against this
tax cut proposal because of the deficits
specifically it's because number one
this tax cut proposal is unethical
because it is a total crony capitalist
handout to the richest Americans as
usual at the expense of poor and
middle-income Americans and number two
because this tax cut proposal is going
to further increase income inequality
while giving tax cuts to people who are
not going to take the money they save
and use it to stimulate the economy so
really good reasons to be against this
tax cut are it's unethical it's immoral
and it's bad for the economy but it is
still 100
valid to point out that by the Wrights
own standards they should be against
this tax cut proposal because of the
deficit exploding effect that it's going
to have it's not a double standard by
the left its accurately pointing out the
double standard from the right okay so
prepare for that red herring that you're
going to hear from the talking heads and
the pundits and everybody else it's
almost boring and passe though right
there's nothing shocking about tax cuts
for the rich blowing up the deficit the
george w bush tax cuts for the rich did
the exact same thing this is just what
happens when you cut taxes for the rich
this is why the simplistic talking
points around taxes from the right are
so destructive and we'll be having some
debates on the program about taxation
sooner than later they create these
simple narratives they take a really
complex issue like taxation and they
reduce it to hey taxes are bad because
it's your money you should keep your
money because it's yours eliminate as
many taxes as possible okay but hold on
a second you don't want to pay taxes and
you don't want to increase the debt but
you also want a stronger and stronger
meaning bigger and bigger military but
you don't want to pay taxes and you
don't want to increase the debt on and
on in this dumb vicious circle so it
doesn't make any sense and along these
lines i want to prepare you for another
talking point that you're going to hear
which originated with trump trump has
said and he might say again that the
scoring by the CBO doesn't take into
account all of the increased revenue for
the government from the new wages and
production of stuff and hiring of people
because these tax cuts will cause growth
do not fall for it there is no evidence
whatsoever period that they can point to
it has never worked that way it will not
work that way no serious economic
analysis tells us that the tax cuts are
going to generate such significant new
government revenue that it's all going
to work out - even in the end it's not
going to happen okay and while we're at
it added one other thing
that is sort of starting to circulate
there are some right-wingers tweeting
posting online that this is better than
Obama because Obama added nine trillion
to the debt over eight years and that
this is only 1.7 trillion over ten years
so it's not quite as bad this 1.7
trillion that's going to be added to the
debt over 10 years that's just the
impact of this tax bill right
it doesn't include everything else
that's going on that will add to the
deficit remember Obama reduced the
deficit but it was still positive so the
debt went up not as quickly as before
but it still went up because we were
running a deficit a smaller deficit and
of course the debt is the sum total of
Prior deficits or surpluses that have
been run Republicans are somewhere in
the in the neighborhood of adding 1.2
trillion to the deficit already running
a 1.2 trillion dollar deficit already
this would per year this will add to
that so don't be tricked by that okay be
prepared for the talking points and
we'll definitely be following the path
of this totally abortive tax plan
through committee for you and will
report on if and when it will pass the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership